I resonate with that heavily
I do feel like I'm pretty baby
no
thank you
I like it this was nice
hey guys what's up my name is Renee Rapp
and I'm here with BuzzFeed to read my
thirst tweets not mine other people's to
me although I do have their sweets at
other people
[Music]
the first one says spoke to Renee rap
for a few minutes it lost his mittens
okay and girly had me blushing and
twirling my hair like a teenager again
thank you
I'm glad you felt that way
the second one says
everyone is so cute girls don't want
boyfriends they want Renee rap
I agree even the straight girls
sometimes baby girl is a 23 year old
woman named Renee Rapp I do feel like
I'm a pretty baby
this is gonna make me sound crazy but
I'll be like baby eat dinner
be like baby it's done for the day or if
I'm like talking to my girlfriend or
some somebody I'll be like Ugh mommy's
had enough I don't like take mommy home
the next one says hot girls love Renee
rap and tummies that hurt that's just a
that's a fact that's in the dictionary
the Bible thesaurus whatever y'all got
that's where that is the next one says I
think the most toxic thing about me is
that I have convinced myself that if I
met Renee rap I could get her to fall in
love with me I actually see this a lot I
don't think that's toxic I think that's
I think that's confidence I think that's
believing in yourself I think that's
having drive and being a hard-working
woman so go for it
the massive Chokehold that Renee Rabb
has on me cry cry crying emojis stop
being so funny and Flirty Girl
no
I did I love to flirt I love to flirt
it's fun it's what keeps the world
spinning everybody needs a little
excitement
the next one says
at Renee rap is Mother
of the mother of the mother who is
mothering the mother I believe you've
confused me for Nicki Minaj
though I appreciate it
thank you that's very sweet and also
actually super hard for me to like read
and understand the next one says Renee
rap is actually gonna bring lesbians and
bisexuals together she will end the
Civil War just by existing and being
sexy
this is very funny
I feel like look the lesbians of
bisexuals were always together man I
know that sometimes there's Flack I get
it that's okay that's okay I mean what
an honor it would be truly I feel like
even as someone who is queer and is
bisexual I constantly am seeking for
like other gay people's approval
like my whole life you especially right
now I'm like wondering if anybody in the
room is gay and if they think I'm funny
and cute
[Music]
yeah that's all I do okay the next one
says Renee rap looked me in the eyes and
called me honey I wish I could breathe
and then there's a lot of like
emojis when I first like started making
friends and like working and you know
doing my thing and I'd be like to
somebody who's like 36 a bit like oh my
God hi baby how are you just because
that's like how that's how you speak to
each other in in the South and in North
Carolina specifically at least it was
where I grew up and then it actually
became a tactic because I can also like
I like using it in situations that are
like very like
like businessy with like people in power
to be honest like it could be some like
grown-ass man and I'll be like
hi baby how are you you know and they'll
just crumble immediately which I use to
my advantage
and I happily will do so the rest of my
life the next one says I think I'm
seriously in love with Renee rap I need
her so bad prove it prove it then Renee
rap is making me feel things I didn't
know I could feel what are those things
tweet them put it out there the way I'm
absolutely feral for Renee rap I love
the word feral we were just talking
about how it's a feral girl summer and
um that's what we're working with so if
you feel the need to be feral act on it
do it the feminine urge to bark
aggressively every time Renee rap comes
on screen
I don't know about that one The Barking
is a little different to me The Barking
goes into kind of a different territory
which I think is great
it's not necessarily my thing The
Barking is like a different kind of
different kind of thing very sexual oh
the next one says no offense but I would
let Renee raps Regina bully me I like a
little mean-spirited
thing like that I think it's cute I've
always been into the whole like bullying
is flirting flirting is bullying
um and I actually don't care where that
comes from and what I need to work on I
really don't care I have fun with it and
I think it's interesting oh well this is
a friend of mine this is from Zara
Larsen she said I just love Renee rap
like
in parentheses me I love you Don I love
you too Renee Rob could drop kick me
straight into hell and I'd thank her I
played soccer and I was a goalie
and I could do that if you want I would
let Renee rap ruin my life I'm Renee
Rapp and I'm ruining my own life woman I
would let humiliate okay I think this
should be women but I hear you women I
would let humiliate and kick me none
because I know my worth and we must love
ourselves two Renee rap
not resonate with that heavily I love
myself but there are women that I would
let ruin my life this next one says
Renee rap is so hot I would let her
choke me no joke legally I can't do that
but thank you Renee rap rail me
I mean
yeah absolutely I look I get it like I'm
reading these tweets and I'm like would
I say this is somebody hell yeah so
thank you
I think
okay right okay I am a a and
a hoe for Renee rap like I really am
what the is she doing to the gays
well again I'm just seeking gay approval
that's what I wake up and I do I too am
a horse and hoe so thank you oh
this is very sweet I just want to remind
everyone of the Perfection that is Renee
rap I would let her buy me sell me
wedgie me throw me off a building or
literally anything she wanted
I'm not very into the whole like owning
of like a person like I'm a pretty like
free world kind of girl so there's a lot
of things in here I wouldn't do
absolutely no shame
I am just a hole for Renee rap
well this was lovely and very sweet and
I feel very flattered and I also like
that we're being so bold I like this
trend of like let's just say what we
mean you know like I think you're hot
kiss me okay
I like it
this was nice
thanks for watching hope you had fun and
thank you for all these very sweet
tweets I'll I'll think about them
tonight before I go to bed and when I
wake up in the morning hope you're
coming to tour and if you're not I hope
you see it online and interact with it
so that it spreads I'd really appreciate
that so do your thing thanks
[Music]
oh
yeah
[Music]